earlier today kenosha county district
attorney michael gravely announced that
no kenosha law enforcement officer will
be charged with any criminal offense
related to the officer-involved shooting
of 29-year-old jacob blake in kenosha
in august of 2020. the marquette
basketball team issued
the following statement earlier today
our program has decided to wear black
uniforms for tonight's game in support
of jacob blake his family and the
kenosha community in reaction to the
announcement earlier today
we're extremely disappointed in the
decision involving jacob's shooting
and we will continue to use our platform
to advocate and fight for racial justice
this is another reminder that just
because racial and social injustice
hasn't received as much attention
recently
doesn't mean the need to fight against
it has gone away again that statement
released earlier today by marquette's
basketball program
the black uniforms warned tonight part
of their efforts to use their platform
to affect
change in
[Music]
on the society now